peaches beaches everywhere welcome to
florida I'm from the Tampa area and here
we have some of the world's best beaches
this next door is Busch Gardens and an
hour's drive from here is the happiest
place on earth at least for us kids
Orlando welcome to Florida come and
enjoy but don't forget you sunglasses
to me being green means reducing our
impact on earth we shouldn't use so many
artificial products and we should start
going natural I think that we could
begin by just turning off the lights
when you leave a room and this saves a
lot of energy
well I would trade places with Freddie
imagining because I think he was the
first person to circumnavigate the world
and he was very confident doing that and
I think also we really find discovering
a place that no one else had ever seen
before and coming back to tell about it
hmm if I could go anywhere in the world
I would definitely go to the golf course
islands with mr. Alex Trebek I would
love to walk in the footsteps of Charles
Darwin and if possible I beg being
marooned they're just like Robinson
Crusoe so then I could make some great
discoveries
my secret that would be keeping my eyes
and ears open you'll get information
from everywhere in the world and my tip
from my teacher is to get 20 new facts
every day and look over them a lot the
more you look at them the more stronger
they become and then in your memory
if ever in charge dirt for a day the
very first problem that I would rather
be global warming I will burn our cars
and make every use the public
transportation by the way they're just
for one day a week
we all know where Britain and Ireland on
do you know where New Britain and my
dinner no not devotional give written in
violent I Popeye
you